hey guys dr. Berg here in this video
I'm gonna talk about skin tags and moles
especially around your neck and your
armpits some people have them they don't
know what causes them basically it's a
real tiny little benign tumor and it's
triggered by a growth factor which
actually is triggered by the hormone
insulin that's why I diabetics or
pre-diabetics start getting these skin
tags around their neck or on their
armpits okay there's other things
that'll happen too but I just want to
kind of give you that that cause effect
relationship and then of course insulin
is the hormone that regulates blood
sugars okay and what happens is that it
will actually first cause the food that
you eat to be stored as sugar that's the
first step up to about 400 grams okay so
the liver so here you you you eat some
sugar right it might not instantly turn
into fat but it'll start to store the
sugar as stored sugar or glycogen in
your liver so and then when it hits 400
grams that's when it starts to convert
to cholesterol in actual fat but the
problem is if you continually eat sugar
or eat too frequently like you're
snacking through the day too much or
grazing at night you're gonna raise
insulin to the point where all of a
sudden you develop like a pre-diabetic
State which is insulin resistance and
you start having higher and higher
amounts of insulin an average person as
insulin resistance has five to seven
times more insulin than a normal person
and because insulin is anabolic it makes
things grow just like estrogen it's a
growth factor it starts producing these
items right here so you need to watch
some of my videos on how to lower insulin
to actually completely get rid of these
right here thanks for watching